They asked me about different products here
Now there's now some of these I don't test for so I
want to
Most products when when people ask me about what about this project? I take this I take this
The majority of them I can honestly say no I tested for that
We don't need to take that yet, and if you're really interested it doesn't mean you still can't take it
But I may have a day or day on these products. So let's kind of go through these
So this person what do you think about cell food or haylocks for oxygenation of cells?
Okay, so cell food is a product on the market. I am familiar with that
Cell food is a product that is
It's got deuterium sulfate in it, and it is kind of sold as
Oxygenized or
tissue
Now I
It'll get this there's a lot of products. I understand first of all
So I don't want to be mean to different supplements that are on the market, but there's a lot of different supplements on the market that
are based on
Really great science sometimes so I struggle with them and
Some of them are put out by like multi level marketing companies, and I don't have anything
Technically against a multi-mill level marketing company, but sometimes I think that they may be more positioned in
Selling a hype on a product that they are really knowing what the product does
So I just I just want to state that I'm not saying that any of these companies do that. I'm just saying that we got to be careful
With what we read out on the internet
So cell food is a deuterium sulfate product. Now I struggle with that because I have some videos on
Another cancer treatment, which is deuterium
Depleted water. So take a step back. What is deuterium? So deuterium is an isotope of
of
Hydrogen so hydrogen is is is
Is
Is it H atom that has just has no neutron?
Deuterium is is an H atom attached to an O2 that has an
Extra neutrons. So it has a neutron
Now that makes so there's hydrogen what so water is H2O
two H's which have a negative
Electron charge attached to an oxygen and
So hydrogen have a positive charge doesn't it doesn't have a neutron attached to an oxygen
So two hydrogens have to attach to an oxygen, which has a negative charge
And then then you have water and we drink water and all the water in the universe here all the water in our world is H2O
But hydrogen in water can exist as a deuterium
hydrogen
O2 so it is still H2O, but it is a
heavier
Hydrogen so it's actually been termed heavy water and there's a percentage of our water
that coming out of your faucet that's coming out of a bottled water that's coming out of the ground you have a well
That there's a percentage depending on where you live in the world. There's a percentage of your water that is
regular what's called
proteome hydrogen
That we would call H2O and there's a percentage that is
Deuterium hydrogen that's still H2O still two hydrogens to an oxygen
So there's a percentage that is deuterium now I can't remember I actually talked about it in the video that I made a few years ago
And I was talking about deuterium depleted water, but I think in the United States or the greater
percentage of the United States it's like
7% of the water you drink is deuterium or something like that
I can't remember that percentage and I didn't look up any of this stuff before this question
So
Trying to just go off memory when I spoke about deuterium depleted water
So this heavy water with this extra with some of the water being deuterium hydrogen
Has been sent to
Cause a shorter lifespan in humans
because it has been shown that
People's one of the things of some people groups that are in blue zones blue zones are people that have more
Centurions more people that live over a hundred years old
There's groups of people in these blue zones
One of the things that they found different with them is that they're drinking water that is
Deuterium depleted. It's got much lower percentage of deuterium in it
And that sparked off all this investigation about two decades ago about what deuterium is and what it does to the human body
Deuterium ages us much quicker
Matter of fact there's some even biblical scholars that have kind of jumped down this way and have said that maybe this is why it bit in the
Old Biblical times pre-flood that to boost but those in the live 900 some years because there was no
Deuterium at all in the atmosphere into the water
So humans lived much longer. Well, it's kind of down the rabbit hole. I don't know if that's true or not
But there is a treatment of cancer that you could drink water that has been
Electronically depleted of deuterium
The hard part is there's only a couple
Centres that actually produce this and it's it's in Europe now
Glacial water is deuterium depleted
In itself, so actually I think what's that Icelandic water bottled water that you can buy I think it's called Icelandic actually has
Actually is deuterium depleted water and a much lesser percentage that if you would spend a lot of money
To buy a gallon of deuterium depleted water from the company who uses this
Diltration type system that's super super expensive that creates deuterium depleted water
so
Long story short self-food has deuterium sulfate in it
I for the life of me when I remember a couple years ago when a patient came and said they were taking self-food
I looked into that product
More extensively. I did not look and I'm sorry and oh, I just saw this question. I separated it apart and put it on
This slide, you know about 15 minutes ago, so I didn't have a chance to dig into it again
But I remember looking at that why are they selling deuterium sulfate I just for the life of me can't figure it out
so
My honest answer with with that product is I don't understand it and I went into this whole offshoot about deuterium and deuterium depleted water
That's another treatment. So I guess you could add that. What about deuterium depleted water?
I
Actually went to a seminar with the expert of deuterium depleted water and he was a
scientist that worked at the company that made
the mechanism that that produced the end product and I had many chats with him because
He had a lot to say there's a lot of studies about cancer
So I did put some of that stuff in the slides
If you do go back to our blog posts search deuterium depleted water, you'll probably come up with the blog post about that
Now halox
So answer for cell food. I just have questions about that
Halox it depends on what we're talking about. So I'm not totally familiar with this product
So there is a hey there is a company that's called hate that has halox
ointment that is
a salicylic acid ointment that's supposed to just decrease paid and it's got some other things in it for inflammation
So I don't know that's exactly what you're talking about. There's another product on the market that's called
halox and it's it's called halo x
So I don't know if it's halo x is what you're talking about
halo x is more of
male
testosterone boosted product
So I'm not sure if you can send me more details on that of this product if
Either one of those are what you're talking about. I'll gladly look at that and research that and can talk to you about it
individually or I can talk to you about it on the next sum call. So I apologize for that